you know how because if in some states
in america if you get caught drink
driving they put a thing on your car you
have to blow into it
yeah yeah yeah some guy like you've made
a video i was like how to avoid doing
that by inhaling alcohol instead
that sounds safe all the comments are
like i feel like you're missing the
point of why
your car but anyway directly like you
get
like in in ava right reckon they just
they just
made like an alcoholic version of like
lcl so you just you just like just get
[ __ ]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of trash taste podcast
where we talk about our trash taste in
anime um gaming whatever i don't
actually we've never talked about gaming
i don't know whatever we have our trash
taste and everything i am your host for
today gigguk and with me
is connor c dog va and joey the anime
man
keeping it real today okay okay i'll cut
you off for that
no facetious nicknames what did you want
to say connor what did you want if
you're mentioning it should we just talk
about games then like what games you've
been playing all right what do you
what have you played recently have you
been playing anime games no i never play
anime games
you never i've never played anything
okay what am i what
what constitutes an anime game though
that's the thing um if the characters go
that's like every game yeah yeah yeah
you could say last of us as an enemy
game and that's
it they have a cute outfit
i don't know like how many games do you
guys play because i
found that i just have zero times to
play a lot of games nowadays
now that the quarantine is over here
right yeah gamer
verified gamer girl as a pro gamer
as a gamer i don't know i feel like uh
it's probably the thing that got cut the
most when i became an adult like out of
everything that i do
watching films doing anything else like
gaming got cut down the most for me
because in universities that's all you
used to do right i used to do gaming for
like 12 hours a day no problem
jesus yeah it was easy i love that [ __ ]
i used to play like legalized events was
a game actually for me like i played
when persona 5 first came out i
definitely started
playing or then 12 hours a day on that i
know like for me the reason i don't play
many games anymore is because
when i get into a game like get into
yeah
i'm like one of those guys who just
can't go like i either have eight hour
gaming sessions
or i just don't game at all there's like
there's like no in between yeah yeah
um like especially if it's like an rpg
or a story driven game
like i remember when persona when i last
played persona 5 it was just like my my
just just block out my week nothing is
happening this week but me
playing persona 5. yeah which is why i
haven't played royal yet
i mean i played persona 5 persona 5
royal and persona 5 scramble
and i think in total that took maybe
like
5 600 hours out of my life this man
finds time where time shouldn't exist
i mean that's what i like about animal
crossing right because i'm still playing
that
to this day and i've put in maybe like
three four hundred hours into that game
but that's the thing right it's like
unlike most gaming sessions where it's
like zero hours or eight hours
yeah animal crossings is one of those
games where you can play for half an
hour and then you can just
drop yeah that's fair enough yeah which
is what i like right it's just like a
little thing to just kind of do on the
sideline as someone who plays league of
legends i feel like
even if it is a 40 minute game session
pro gamer here that [ __ ] felt like eight
hours
the mental battle that it took to play a
game of league of legends took
eight hours yeah but i [ __ ] used to
love playing league of legends man i'm
so addicted are there any like actual
like games based off anime that you guys
like
or what do you mean like what by anime
games i don't mean like
games with anime looking characters like
i'm not talking about like a xenoblade
or like a dragon quest 11 kind of has
there
ever been a good anime spin off i'm sure
that has no idea it's just i can't
really think of any right now
i mean like you know all the attack on
titan game on steam i was like yo i'm so
hyped i get 10 minutes into the game
like
huh probably dragon ball fighters
that's that's you like the fighting
games i mean i i'm i'm not really much
of a fight game enthusiast but i mean i
had fun playing it and i think it was a
pretty good
i enjoyed um what was the the latest
like naruto fighting game
like i'm not a huge fan of naruto 17.
something like that i don't know like
the latest one on that on steam like uh
i think someone gifted that to me
and i just gave it a go but i was like
you know i'm not that much of an
advocate for like fighting games i'm not
that good at fighting games and i'm not
much of a fan of the naruto franchise
but i gave it a go that game is
genuinely fun
right i mean you have um what's the
what's the pokemon
fighting game oh pokken i like pockets
yeah it's good i like it if you like
pokken it's it's similar to that just
with naruto
no one ever wants to play pokemon
pokemon it's so fun it's good though
because
i do you know you bring your switch to a
party right you're like i've got mario
party
i've got mario kart i've got all these
amazing multiplayer games right yeah the
last thing anyone wants to play is
pocket but if people give it a chance
it's actually fun yeah i don't think
it's a great game but it's really fun
it's
fun it's really really fun yeah it's
just like a brain dead fighting game
it's really easy
yeah a lot but i think it needed to be
because i suck at fighting games well
here's his question for you guys and
have you ever
watched an anime and thought this would
be a really cool game
because i i can think of one off the top
of my head
sorry i would saw an awesome line be a
good game though i've played the sword
online games they all suck
wait there's one in the arcade room yeah
and i'm not just saying that because i
don't like solo online like genuinely
they also i just had a huge epiphany
well the jojo battle uh the jojo
fortnight the georgia falls
game fortnight yeah there's a in japan
they have an arcade game
and it's a battle royale of jojo and you
go around mario
and and all you do is like try and
[ __ ] punch each other to death it's
so fun that game's fun it's kind of bad
it's kind of a bad game it
kind of sucks but it's but it's good
it's [ __ ] great
um because like i i completely forgot
about japanese arcades as well
we even spoke about that yeah we haven't
spoken about that my second home baby
i'm not in an arcade i was at an arcade
just yesterday actually because i i
wanted to get uh what's that piano game
that you and i are really into it's like
nos not nostalgia i think it's called
things i think it's something like that
basically
in japanese japanese arcades are [ __ ]
next level yeah like like it's
like rk's just didn't die here and
there's so many cool things about
japanese arcades that you just can't get
anywhere else in the world if you think
american arcades are fun you will not
in a japanese yeah yeah exactly it's a
different experience from arcade because
growing up my arcade experience is
always like kind of like
you know uh house of the dead those type
of people yeah yeah like party games
yeah time crisis right that's like th
and they do have those i'd say those are
the only games that really translated
well from like western arcades like
maybe dance revolution as well
i don't know because like uh japanese
arcades have so many rhythm games
it's like 80 rhythm games but it's
they've got so many unique
ideas about video games because i
remember when i was like when before i
came to a japanese arcade i was like oh
yeah
rhythm games aren't really my thing you
know i didn't really enjoy ddr
all that kind of stuff and then i went
to a japanese arcade and there are just
so many different types of rhythm games
and it's [ __ ] crazy
i mean i thought i thought after you
know playing guitar here and just
pretending to be a band or
what was it rock band rock band playing
basically every instrument i was like
rhythm games aren't going to get better
than this because you're pretending to
play the instruments yeah and then
japanese okay to be like now how about
we just
invent instruments yeah you see you see
this dj
board right here yeah six buttons you're
a dj now
and it feels amazing when you like turn
the knobs and stuff like that
oh okay i'm making some music right now
goddamn
yeah but no i was the exact same like
i've always liked rhythm games
yeah before you know like rhythm heaven
and stuff like that on the ds like i
played
the [ __ ] out of those games loved it um
but
when i moved here i was the exact same
right i was like
not a huge fan of ddr you never really
played a lot of rhythm games like in
western
arcades and i didn't really even have an
arcade in australia
yeah we didn't do we didn't really have
an arcade that was nearby enough like we
had one in the city
yeah there's one that was really far
away from me yeah but like the city for
me where i live is like 45 minute drive
oh [ __ ] so to a 14 year old it might as
well be in a different country yeah yeah
yeah
so my only experience with arcades is
the japanese arcades
yeah but even when i was little i would
go to a japanese arcade and i never
really touched the rhythm games because
yeah all these like high school kids are
around and as a 10 year old you don't
want to go into that crowd
those dudes on the on some of these
games are insane you know you know
someone is like insane when there's like
a 16 year old
just rocking up in front of the tune of
the machine and he just puts his gloves
on the gloves
if they wear gloves they're like serious
yeah it's like that anime moment you
know when
you put on the glove it's like it's on
the gloves he just does the
the shine and he just gets ready like he
they just stretches and [ __ ] i'm just
like is it
that the game where they go like this
yeah yeah yeah they for some reason i
don't know why all the good players do
it there must be a trick there but they
all throw their hands in the air when
they're playing i think i think
i've played tuna before that's an actual
movement
what did you say don't worry about it
i'm going to see the replay no but like
i played
near them once because i was also just
like that's an actual movement you need
to do you have to
there's a sensor in the actual board
that senses your hands moving
up yeah yeah yeah but a lot of them do
it like when they've you know in the
movies
or they finish their piano solo and they
just like raise their hand yeah yeah
they go high yeah it looks like it looks
like you know a classical pianist
just finishing their performance right
but they're doing it
every time i mean like they're almost
putting in as many inputs as like a
japanese pianist like
a professional pianist sometimes it's it
looks so cool though
when someone's good you're like man this
this is this is amazing this is like a
spectator sport right here yeah
but then you think about man how many
100 yen coins did they have to go
through
to get to that level to be further you
get like three songs most of the time so
about 10 minutes for about
100 yen which is yeah less than a dollar
so wait so what are the go-to rhythm
games for you guys at an rk
um i like the one you showed me i can't
remember it it was cool but it's one way
it's like a massive circle
oh yeah yeah yeah and
basically it's it's it's a really unique
input input where it's like the entire
circle
and you have to like follow the lines
and everything like that we'll have a
video on screen
yeah yeah it's it's it was something
that it's written games like this that
you just can't i
i've just never seen before yeah i
should have burned my fingers though
it was the first time i considered i was
like should i buy gloves
because it's like a plastic thing right
and some of the inputs are like do a
full 360 with your hand so you're just
sliding your
sweaty palms all around this thing and
you're like
trying to get your hands around i was
like oh that's where the gloves come in
here because the thing is
they're they're they're not buttons as
well they're all just sensors so you see
you're just here like
smashing this smashing this hard surface
like
dude and it just it hurts your fingers
oh my god [ __ ] hurt
hurts i love the like the piano one but
that's because it's basically
what's the other piano one with the guys
do the thing in the air what's it called
uh tune in them
that i feel like that's the hard version
and the one that i like is the easy one
because
yeah it's like a piano thing but you
don't have to actually hit the right
just just close something that's close
just
somewhere so you just so you basically
look at the screen you just do it's
really like
beginner friendly and i really like it
because a lot of them like there's i
feel
the problem with a lot of the the games
is there's medium
and then there's [ __ ] insane like
there's there's no in between
and i always had this problem with
guitar hero yeah where like i could do
medium fine
but when we put the little pinky
involved that's when it all fell apart
like
i couldn't do it but it makes you feel
like a piano oh my god shut the [ __ ] up
all the classic the uh the taiko drums
right oh yeah
yeah that's that's like whenever you
bring someone you're like get off the
club yeah come on you'll enjoy this it's
so easy to understand right
it's like monkey brain mode i hit two
places okay i understand
yeah what about you uh i mean the one i
always go to
is a groove coaster oh you always play
rooftop it looks cool though groove
coast is fun
which one's that one groove coaster is
the one with the giant it's like pure
adhd and there's
two like bulbs that you have to move
around and tap yeah i
sucked at it at first but then i went to
this con in uh washington dc like
two years ago maybe three years ago
right and they had a groove coaster
machine but no one was in front of it
and at this point i'd never played
groove coaster before yeah
and i just saw this groove coaster
machine that nobody was lining up in
front of
and it was free to play yeah yeah and
the concept the whole car yeah yeah yeah
so i was like i've got like two hours to
kill [ __ ] it and no one's lighting up in
front of this thing let's do it and i
got
so good in those two hours where i was
like
actually get on these machines yeah and
then ever since then i've loved it
and there's also uh what's that what's
the other one what's the cube one keep
getting oh the one where you like tap
the things yeah yeah you have the things
in time
that's cool that one's really yeah yeah
that's like a classic drone game in the
japanese yeah because i remember my
first experience with like japanese
arcade games it was
there's always that fear where you're
just like i have no idea what i'm doing
you know what i mean like especially at
conventions when there's always
that guy yeah that guy who just like and
he's always before you as well
he comes up with the excel spreadsheet
on the best technique
it's like all right i just wanted to
play the game but yeah yeah and you're
just you're just standing there being
like
what buttons do i press like i don't
even know any of these songs it's time
crisis
yeah and it's always like it's always
the worst continents as well because you
know there's people standing around you
oh no
judging you so hard it's like look at
this [ __ ] when you're like if you're
like a guest there everyone's gonna look
at you you're like
you sucked at ddr do you have any
comments about that
sucker but that's what i love about like
japanese arcades is that you can just
spend
you can just lose so many hours in there
and it's it's really easy
because it's oh and you get the cards
yeah i was going to talk about
sorry like basically actually you you
explained joe because you're the one who
did it for me so you probably know the
process better than me so
different machines are owned by i guess
different
rhythm game companies or whatever yeah
yeah and you can if you get
so good at it you can uh buy these cards
for like 300 yen which is nothing it's
like three dollars
um and you print them out and you can
save your progress on it because it's a
it's a public
rhythm game so if you just put the money
in you're treated as a guest
so your records for whatever you do
yeah yeah high scores that kind of stuff
doesn't get saved because you're just a
guest
so if you get so invested in a
particular rhythm game or a number of
rhythm games
you can buy these cards um and to you
know save your records and stuff like
that and you can
a lot of japanese people i know like
share it online to yeah
yeah and like i recommend getting it
anyway because there are some rhythm
games like the piano one
that if you don't have a card they're
going to make you sit through the
tutorial
and there's no way to skip it exactly
like i remember i i i really enjoyed it
and i went to
i went to the arcade on three separate
occasions and for the first like
three minutes i was just sitting there
being like remember i finished my first
two songs i'm like you know the tutorial
yet
i was still doing the tutorial every
time so i was like i gotta get [ __ ]
card i need a card yeah
and the good thing is as well with those
cards is that not only the cheap but
a lot of the cards the first game that
you do
with the card is usually free so you
actually make that money back yeah yeah
yeah
so like the with groove coaster at least
when you get uh it's called a nesca card
because yeah there's nesca
and then there's a few other ones yeah
then there's the bandai one and so
i have that yeah so with the nesca card
at least when you the first game of
groove coaster you play
is free because you just put that money
into the card
right which is which i think is a nice
compromise because it doesn't feel like
you just you know you're paying extra to
save your progress essentially and you
can you like you'll only have a set
amount of stages as a guest
yeah and if you you know level up you
would learn more stages
yeah yeah exactly it's just it's just
cool to like go back to an arcade you
know every
so often just like your favorite anime
yeah yeah i got to triple s this stage
man i just have to i
have to invest they have undertale on
groove coaster right yeah they have the
entire soundtrack
i'm [ __ ] yeah dude i can do level 12
megalovania like triple s
i was pretty proud of myself cool
because the uh on groove coaster they
have like
special animations just for the
undertale song so oh really it looks
like an undertale game playing out on oh
no that's every song
yeah yeah but even all the vocaloid
stuff as well they use like the music
videos for it and that's what i love
about groove coaster because every stage
actually looks really unique as well
because it has to match the song
have you tried using your card at the
ones in america have you ever tried that
no
i should try that that's just that that
would be pretty cool if it weren't if
you're at a convention and you just
you just probably wouldn't right because
whip out the card right yeah probably
need to be connected to the internet
i gotta i gotta flex on these people
that i triple s megalovania
level 12 you know oh you don't have all
the stages yeah oh
how do you guys feel about like the ufo
machines or like what like the prize
machines here in japan aki's [ __ ]
amazing at it and i
don't know how she because what really
surprised me is that
most in most in everywhere else is kind
of like a luck kind of like
like one based but in here i see people
who are just really good
at these machines and they can actually
turn it into a profit because
then they just sell the figures or
whatever you get or buy
that's a huge industry as well yeah yeah
that's a big deal like a lot of the
stores in akihabara are selling crane
game stuff
yeah how did they get i i just don't
understand how people can get good at
that because
aki's every time we go to an arcade aki
always is less like [ __ ] the rhythm
games
i'm just gonna go to the crane games to
just get random [ __ ] but every time i
try it and she's standing next to me
she's always like oh no you should move
them all to the right
wait how do you know that i was just
[ __ ] going for it but
there's like a whole like secret thing
where it's like yeah you have to aim it
slightly to the left so that it drags
the plushie closer to the hole
how do you figure that [ __ ] out i just
want to go beep beep and pick up
like i don't want to i don't want to
think about this i want to just play it
i guess you have to if you want to like
not spend as much money but if i really
really want the thing
in the crane i'll just go to the shop
next door that probably is selling it
used for like 800 yen which is way
cheaper than it would be yeah every time
you go to an
arcade in akihabara there's always the
store next to it is the exact thing
you're trying to gamble for but in japan
if you
mess up enough and you put enough money
in the machine the staff will come over
and be like
uh hey you you wanna you're on help we
feel we feel kind of bad you've spent
like
how many thousands of years yeah which
is why like when i have friends who are
doing it who are [ __ ] up loads and
they put like 20 bucks i'm like
do it put like 10 more bucks in then
i'll call the staff over yeah
and if you do that normally they'll
place it they'll pick it up
literally put it on the box yeah and
just require you to like tap
it yeah like they'll pretty much set it
up for you baby modes baby mode
activated
literally
have you ever seen a crane game at the
conventions in america
no i haven't actually i've seen them but
i've always been scared to try them
i guess because you can set the crane
game to how difficult you want it yeah
and just knowing how like a lot of at
least american
crane games that i've played i mean how
they might as well just be
like there might as well not be it's
it's basically just a slot machine with
the claw attached
yeah you know what i mean exactly yeah
i rather put my money into this actual
slot machine than a crane game which i
would not rather do anyway yeah
yeah yeah but no there's like a lot of
different games that you just don't see
anywhere else
in arcades like i don't know why there's
always there's always a fake go
like section that's it's it's not just
one machine
there's an entire round there's a row of
fake machines in every [ __ ] arcade i
swear to god and those machines have you
played on those machines i haven't yet
[ __ ] expensive what what what is it
i've never played the game
the cards right yeah it's it's so
they're expensive because you can print
out physical cards
of the waifus that you get in fake gold
oh yo for real yeah
oh you don't know that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
surprise oh
[ __ ] they're no cause you'll be broke
don't
don't know so nabi one of my best
friends here um
he is like a super heavy like fake go
player i mean he used to be
aka he has no money yeah aka he's broke
right so i don't need to give fate
anymore
don't
because i went to an arcade with him and
he was like oh can i just go onto the
fake go machines i'm like yeah actually
because
i've always wanted to know what they
were i've always walked past them and
yeah it's like it's like a double screen
it's like a giant
ds essentially where the bottom screen
is like a touch screen
and you have these packet of cards and
you can essentially use
cards to summon fake characters
that's so cool oh my god you're showing
me this
it's like you use the fate characters to
like beat like a certain quest it's kind
of like dragon quest with fake
characters
and if you beat a certain quest and
depending on how you beat it
then you can unlock different waifus and
you can actually print out the waifus
from the machine don't tell him
and like just play one game is already
expensive enough but of course they take
money to like actually print out the
cards
so it's just like so much money for the
franchise right now and i know
after today you're going to go to you're
just going to see me in a week and just
like guys i've sung way too much money
she's going to come in with like a deck
like why why why did you say you never
went on it considering you made that
whole
gacha video i mean like because it
because of quarantine like
it was current scene that started my
process for the gacha video so i haven't
actually been to an arcade since
quarantine started so i've just been
playing fago and so i know what we're
doing after this episode
we're going to an arcade that has a fake
go machine it's like skylanders but for
questionable adults that's what it
sounds like
you can like summon the cards oh okay i
mean i mean to be fair
it's pretty fun i mean that's that's
basically gotcha games okay not showing
yeah exactly i mean you're just you're
just collecting pngs or cards or
whatever the literal png's printed out
yeah yeah yeah yeah wait so you're
telling me that we're not just
collecting pngs
but they're physical and printed out bro
laminated cards
want a png always appears man
you know the coolest game i ever saw on
an arcade here was you know typing of
the dead it's actually an arcade machine
yeah it's in akihabara it's on like the
one of the sega buildings
they have like four sega buildings yeah
one of them one of them there's there's
they the typing of the dead mod they
actually have a typing of the dead so
it's a house that does but you type
yeah so what there's like a keyboard
it's a keyboard two keyboards right
actually oh that's slowly
typical it's so [ __ ] quiet you get a
picture of it yeah that's so cool i
remember being next to the game where
you tipped the table
there's no one arcade game in japan
where all you do
is like you have to tip this table as
hard as possible you know you know in
like american arcades they have the
punching machines
yeah it's that but instead of punching
something you just lift the tail yeah
yeah yeah
you flip it as hard as you can on the
screen right now there'll be a reference
but yeah
it's really [ __ ] cool yeah it's very
fun it's like but it's kind of expensive
because you get one flip
yeah and then you better make that
that better sounds [ __ ] amazing yeah
it's good it's only in japan only in
japan
why else would you want to flip a table
like i don't know what table in real
life
where else can you flip a table in real
life and just get away with it yeah
you'll have to clean up the dress
not only get away with it but be
rewarded
well done you got a high score in your
like home countries did you ever have
like these
arcades at home where they would they
would like have this one japanese arcade
machine
and that like everyone would be honest
in in wales they didn't but in london
they did yeah in london there's a few i
remember there was one arcade machine
called like i think it was bishibashi
i love that game yeah yeah but like in
london it was like a really really
old like okay it was beating up and in
here like i didn't realize there was
like new iterated versions of it right
right yeah bishibashi is a lot of fun
it's just basically like
mario party you want to crash with only
one mechanic
yeah you have to press your button in
certain ways with one button i mean
ishibashi means to hit oh yeah yeah
that's why because there's some
some games you just like yeah [ __ ]
spamming it i love those games
it's a fun game you should play it if
you have a camera yeah it's super fun
yeah basically like i feel like
one of some of the one of the weeb
experiences go to akihabara but i feel
like you'd be missing half that by not
going to an arcade as well
yeah and that's the good thing about
japanese arcades right is that you don't
have to go to occupy harborough to
experience no no you don't
literally everywhere yeah it's
definitely like a different
gaming experience from normal gaming in
a way that like it's hard to
quantify the value of i guess because as
a gamer right
i love i love i love spending ten hours
a day playing video games but like i
i can't spend more than like four hours
in an arcade in japan yeah
it's hard yeah it depends on the game
for me yeah i mean i i think nowadays
it's hot as well
yeah oh it's so funny and if you're on
the floor they smoke
like because there's always one floor
where you're allowed to smoke yeah yeah
oh my god that floor reeks
oh yeah yeah i mean i feel like nowadays
i probably have a little bit of an
easier time because i've
kind of diversified my rhythm gameplay
bring headphones bring headphones
oh yeah bring headphones bring your own
headphones you need an uh an aux cord
basically yeah yeah but if you don't
then you're going to try and play a
rhythm game while you're hearing 50
others yeah yeah at the same time
i think that's why it's so hard for me
to sit down most times before
for like months i didn't use headphones
i couldn't get into it but when i put
headphones on
i just do like maybe like an hour but i
can't sit there
it feels so good because i remember the
first time i tried the piano machine and
i didn't have headphones and i'm just
like i can't even
hear the music so i'm just i'm just
playing press the color yeah you know
what i mean like like
i'm i'm it's not there's no rhythm to
this game i'm just smashing
what i see on screen yeah like with
headphones i'm like oh this
this feels good
i feel like a [ __ ] master at playing
piano and i'm here i'm just like
like smashing something so
when it comes to like actual anime games
like games that are based off
of anime right which ones have you done
because we briefly mentioned about the
the dragon ball
fighting games with the naruto fighting
games but have you guys played any
recently i don't think so because the
only
games anime games i can think of that
played recently are all like
mobile games or like catch games right
you know that
do they really count as games i mean
yeah they're kind of in a league of
their own yeah
i feel like that's a separate genre
right i'm a pure multiplayer slave
sorry i think there's like no anime
games in like the multiplayer
yeah because because the recent anime
game that i played
which apparently no one [ __ ] played
was the fifth of the north star game oh
cause it was a it was like a skin on a
yakuza yeah it was basically it was done
by the people who did the arkansas
and i mean i [ __ ] love this than
all-star so when i saw that and i was
like oh it's basically just a
yakuza game i was like hell yeah i
played it that game is so [ __ ] fun
if you like no one played it if you like
the yakuza games no but here's the thing
i've never played a yakuza game oh okay
i've only heard about yakuza games
because
a lot of my friends yeah yeah yeah but i
was just more drawn to the fact that it
was a fist of an all-star game and it
looked
[ __ ] amazing i i saw cliff he's like
yeah
dude you can do the um in the game and i
was like oh
yes so fun it's so good i love it yeah
but um did that get localized over to
the west
i'm pretty sure i did i saw a few of my
stream friends playing it okay
yeah i saw a few reviews when it came
out and it was just kind of like yeah
it's a yakuza game
yeah do you guys remember when when jump
force was announced
oh my god oh [ __ ]
that was hilarious oh my god it was the
beautiful irony that
a a game about anime characters had some
of the worst cut scenes imaginable i
don't know
i just i just remember the scene where i
think it was freezer or something just
like
floating up
that's the problem with anime games
recently because i don't know if the
game will be out
by the time this episode is out but
right now i'm doing a video where i
collect a bunch of
old retro anime games that never made it
out of yeah yeah to like kind of
review anime games because like the
general consensus i feel with
anime-based games
at least in the west is that they're
very much a modern endeavor
it's like only recently that now anime's
becoming a lot more of a mainstream
thing in the west that
they're finally starting to capitalize
on the western market and
but you know in retrospect anime games
have been around since like
the nes supernatural yeah yeah yeah
period they just never made it out of
japan
but it's so unfortunate that now all
these like people in the west who love
anime
are finally starting to get kind of a
glimpse into like anime based games
yeah and yet you get [ __ ] like jump
force and one piece world
seeker that one piece game i saw footage
of that oh my god
the frame rate was garbage dude i could
i was i was kind of looking forward to
that game too because i'm like
maybe finally finally we'll get a good
one-piece adventure game
no we did not i mean the problem with
anime games a lot of anime games for me
is they just look like
a quick cash grab you know what i mean
they want to make it look triple a but
they're not willing to put the money in
yeah yeah
actually i remember like la i think it
was last year the year before there was
like a mahira academia game
they all look the same they all look
janky as [ __ ] yeah
and yeah i i don't know like i haven't
like i you and then you read some of the
reviews and nothing really sells you on
this game versus this
hey this actual aaa game or something
that has nothing to do with anime
like i don't have enough time to play
games enough as it is let alone play
i'm not playing a [ __ ] game yeah yeah if
you're gonna get me off like the games
i'm cripplingly addicted to it better be
[ __ ] good
right right it better be arc nights
better nights
of the wild was one game that like
managed to tame me oh yeah oh
everybody ever yeah the only thing that
tears me away from like league of
legends is another multiplayer thing
where i could just keep grinding and
yeah
i remember when i first played breath of
the wild because when i first played
breath of the wild was when i first came
to japan
and i remember it was it was great
because i was like it was my first time
experiencing japan
seeing all the stuff and all i can think
of is i just want to go home so i could
just
just i had the exact spot i
i need to i need to go to that temple
man like there's this part of the map
that's unexplored i want to hit that up
i remember playing in the bathtub like i
was so addicted that even my bathing
i had to be playing it i have to utilize
it every amount of time yeah i remember
i was in that [ __ ]
fire dungeon the wind dungeon thing yeah
yeah yeah
dude was terrible i recently during uh
at the beginning of quarantine i
decided to get back into uh breath of
the wild but this time i played it on
pro mode
wow wow you're such a i know epic game
of girl moment
but the only difference between pro mode
and regular mode is that on the the main
hud
like you know how when you're playing
breath of the wild there's like the mini
map in the corner like the temperature
time of day
yeah yeah yeah pro mode basically takes
all of that away and just shows your
heart
right so you're forced to explore and
look around
and when i played it i was like this is
how the game's supposed to be played
because i discovered more things in the
first
elitist because i discovered
more [ __ ] in the first 10 minutes of
promo than i did
in the first couple of hours of regular
game day because [ __ ] are you doing in
the regular game because in the regular
game mode you have the mini map right so
you're forced to like go to the
closest shiny thing that you see on the
menu yeah yeah whereas in pro mode
you have to [ __ ] look around and i
was like oh [ __ ] i didn't know there was
a temple right here
like right under my feet because i'm too
yeah that's true [ __ ] worried about
going to this tower that the the game is
telling you
pro gamer at that moment i was like
this is this is epic gamer girl right
here
on the topic of anime games though how
do you guys feel about visual novels
and uh i [ __ ] love them yeah have you
ever played one i've never played a
visual novel
i i was i had a moment during high
school where all i played was visual
norms i
i remember i i've booted them up several
times and every single time
i get about five minutes in i'm like hey
this is just a book
in disguise that's true they're trying
to trick me into this
this is just a book with extra pictures
like
it's a book with extra steps it's like
it's like a novel
but there's like visuals to it what the
[ __ ]
i think the best example i ever heard
was my friend saying this is just an
audio book with pictures
some of them don't even have voice
acting yeah it's an audiobook with
pictures but the main character never
has the voice
because they want you to immerse i don't
know i just i'm sure there's a lot of
people
at home who are watching this as well
who holes are in the same boat as me
where i'm like
it's too funny oh no i don't i don't
blame you i don't blame you anybody
who says that they can't get into visual
models is it in the same category as
gaming like it comes not right i was
going to say because like i'm a gamer i
don't know
i'm a gamer there's there's like there's
there's like different
levels i feel like because like okay so
like
like in a game no no no i i hate
no cause like it took me like years
because as
as a kid i would play with my ds like i
was a nintendo kid right so i had like a
ds
would would like play play on that a lot
and then it took me years to realize
wait a minute phoenix wright is just a
visual novel
i never liked finnish writing did you
know you're trying to trick me into
thinking
oh i love phoenix all right i love
phoenix right now you tricked me into
thinking
let me get let me shoot things where is
that high octane gameplay that's what
the
yeah yeah but that's what that's what
when i try to play phoenix right i'm
like this isn't a puzzle game
they're trying to trick me into thinking
i'm using my brain i'm just reading the
whole time
weirdly enough i got into the visual
novels because i
really heavily gone into era gays oh my
goodness yes yes i started yes
i started with error gaze and that's my
brother that's my brother i started with
arrogance obviously because i am a 13
year old horny boy on my own
what's wait what's what what what's the
first official novel that you played why
didn't you just watch porn if you were
what's wrong you're not
you're in google you have all the google
and you think i want to read the pawn
because okay okay no it's not before
before you get to the porn you need to
like it it doesn't feel as good if you
just if they just hand it to you
right you you earned you earned that you
don't read the porn you experienced
the point yeah yeah so how old are you
guys when you got into this first of all
uh arrogance yeah like 14. 13 14. when i
was 14
right my mum could have come in the room
at any second right
this needed to be like like special ops
precision
i needed to get in and out and get the
get the deed done because
you know i you know could you did you
have like two floors dude in the house
no i have one full no no no no i had two
floors but we're all on the same okay so
my bedroom's on the second right right i
had about a five second window where i
could hear the stairs creaking
i i don't know which room she was going
into but just in case i had to prepare
every time
during those five seconds just the
mission impossible things like playing
in your head is like then you're like
ready just in case my mom was gonna walk
in the room right
and it was playing with how did you have
the time to get into a story
right and with that without any of your
parents finding you watching porn
because i was one of those kids that had
a lock on his door your parents gave you
a lock
yeah bro my parents would never give me
actually my like my my the only computer
we had in my household was like the
family community
laptop yeah yeah like i was watching
porn on the family life because my dad
was
has been working in an it company for 30
years so he gave everybody like our own
computers
yeah he didn't have to like work around
schedules
but like like i had like i knew because
my parents would they would always be
out in several uh like
specific hours of the day for work
so i'd be like okay it's it's it's
aerogate time
i would just like 10 minutes get the d
done go back to gaming
i don't even remember what the first
arrow game was that i played it was i
remember what it was shitty
i remember what it was for me it was
called the sagara family or something
like that
and how i discussed and how i discovered
it right
this this is this is like going before
era gaze but it was technically
arrogance
did you guys ever go through that phase
where you're just playing shitty
like hentai visual novels on new grounds
yeah yeah yeah
frank's adventure that was the [ __ ] are
you kidding me
like a gun guru girl oh
hentai sexy
this was two hobbies that you should not
have combined at a young age
that just like blew the biggest wave of
nostalgia
yeah do you remember right you remember
of course i do
when you and you see that like red
letter a i was like
yeah it's my game boys let's go
it was so good it was like it was so
shitty because you know this was made by
like
one dude and living in like the middle
of [ __ ] like
you know winnipeg yeah it's like mom's
basement being like i'm gonna make a
really
shitty like hentai flash game but like
as
as a kid at that time that was like the
only exposure you can get yeah so you
were just like
holy [ __ ] because i was too afraid at
that moment to like go on to
google images to like look because i
didn't know how to search for that [ __ ]
right
no okay so you're telling me you know
how to find pawn games
but you didn't know how to find porn
yeah because on new grounds it's they
have an entire section i don't know if
it's still to this day but yeah
back then on newgrounds there was an
entire adult section that clearly just
said adult
so you knew that if you clicked on that
part of the website
every game or animation that came up was
going to be of that color exactly and
they were all
hentai games they were all hentai games
why not just watch porn i don't
know because you don't know how to look
it up yeah because because you're good
no no no no pornhub didn't exist you
know it's like
when did pornhub come around i don't
like when i was like this this is
sixteen
like like this is show my agenda but
this was before the age of streaming
okay like okay like an anime boomerang
like so so what do you do if you need to
find porn but you can't stream it
and i thought when was like when did
google get popularized
because i remember back then i was
probably using yahoo or ask jeeves
jeeves where is the porn where is brazos
jeeves
because the reason i discovered uh
sagara family was because
you know in those um hentai vis uh like
the
new grounds visual novels you you don't
give up you know what i'm talking about
i know what you're talking about they
would have they would always like the
porn part would always be these gifts
yeah yeah yeah of and then i saw one of
the comments and they were like they
they were like oh
they they sourced the gif yeah yeah and
so that's how i
that's what introduced that to the world
of error that's how i found my first
arrow game as well because yes
i i played like frank's adventure or
whatever the [ __ ] it was and
there was this section where it's like
you walk into a cinema
but like the cinema is mosaic and you
have to get like a special item from
somewhere to like
unlock the mosaic and when you finally
did it was this like gif
of this like or this image it wasn't
even a gif because it was from an
irrigate it was just this
this gif or this png of just this like
really all like 90s arrogant
yeah yeah yeah my 13 year old brain was
like [ __ ] yeah
what is that give me the sauce yeah and
i grow
to the scroll to the comments and of
course there was that one also horny on
me 13 year old who was like
hey uh at this part of the game
where's she from where where would where
does this image come from
and of course there was this cultured
boy was like my mans i got you
probably from reddit or 4chan at the
time i was like i got you bro
yeah yeah i came i came from the a board
that's where all the sources yeah
and yeah and and then i would finally
look it up yeah and of course back then
you know the
[ __ ] wild west of the internet you
could get games like that
very easily you can get it easily it
just took like
two millennia to download exactly
because i remember like because i could
only download it when my parents were
out
so what is this two gigabyte
yeah cameras was like gigabytes and i'm
like oh this is this is gonna take
time so back then like it would like i i
would have to like plan this [ __ ] out
this was like scheduled
where okay yeah yeah you had about [ __ ]
is doing a special ops operation you
irrigate down
[Laughter]
and i hated it when you would go onto
the website and it's like you can only
download
you would download part one of 76 raw
file
and you finally get and you and you
realize it's like 200 meg it's like all
right that won't take too long and you
download it and you go to download part
2 and it's like you have to wait 15
minutes in the next one i'm just like
god damn it so like so like what what is
the struggles i do not identify so like
when i actually down and sometimes like
one one of the parts would be missing
and it was just the most
it was the most angry moment you can
think of because you you
you've downloaded 40 files you just need
one more file you you go on winrar you
try to extract it
there's an error what the [ __ ] do you do
there's this exactly because i'm like no
no no
because i i remember so many times i
would just
read it about this i remember something
i wanted that lesson please
because when when you've when you've
invested so much time downloading this
and there's just one file there are so
many hentai games i've never played
because there's just one file missing
and i couldn't find that's the problem
it's like unlike you know
previously we talked about like how part
three out of eight of this anime movie
was missing
you could still watch the other seven
parts but with error gaze with winrar
you're missing one part you can't play
any of this sounds like [ __ ] harry
potter hunting down the hall like i
i just realized how close that story was
to the youtube story that we told a few
weeks ago about watching anime in past
but imagine
imagine if you don't if imagine if
you're missing one part just you just
don't watch the entire
and that's why when all those parts did
successfully download
and did successfully extract and you
booted it up yeah the moment a window
popped up and it wasn't like
spyware it was just like yes now
i can finally put in the time that i had
spent so long trying to get
and i did put in the time no matter how
shitty the arrogant was because i
remember
my first couple of very i didn't know
what a good arrogant was no no i just
downloaded whatever the [ __ ] i saw on
you guys it was a victory the fact that
you got it working
yeah and you're like i'm gonna play this
and i'm gonna [ __ ] enjoy it and it
was amazing
i'm gonna 100 complete this [ __ ] if it
kills me damn i was just playing
runescape
you guys going you guys sound like
you're going through a [ __ ] mission
just to get something working yeah but
it was so worse just
yeah like what one third of a 2d tit is
that that's what it was because
that was that was like how hard it was
to get porn back in the day
like goku runescape selling gf buying gf
actually actually have a funny story oh
[ __ ] okay no no because like
because like okay this is this was like
when i was a kid right and
you know with like when you first
discover like the concept of like sex
and porn
and like i didn't like we had dial-up
internet back then yeah same so yeah
but like this this was this was going
back when i was like 9
10 you know yeah before before i could
really like
have time to work on a computer and
everything like that so
um i would like the only way i could get
anything close to that was by watching
like late night tv shows
right okay in the uk so
um so what i tried to do as a kid was i
would
like i would record shows on my vhs
i did that as well right okay okay but
there's but there was this one show
because i looked at the tv guide there
was this one show what i did
there was this one show that was like oh
this sounds spicy as a kid i'm like
oh this this sounds exactly what i'm
looking for it was a late night tv show
edit like 12.
is it is it can i say the title is it
okay is it called babe station
no no no
no the show was called sex in the city
so me being a nine-year-old kid thinking
i'm about to get porn right now
and then i i said i set my vhs up i
i go to sleep the vhs records and i've
never been
more disappointed as a kid like imagine
it as a kid
you think you're about to get full-on
sex for the first time you could have
seen it
and the city right and you just get a
bunch of girls talking about
dick and shoes like i was like what
what is this this is false advertising
do you know how much effort i had to put
in to record this show and this is what
i get
i i remember as well as like i was like
a 12 year old 13 year old and just
hearing that like my mom's friend
favorite show was sex in the scene i was
like that's not very christian
what the [ __ ] man adults are scary
all right but hold on we gotta hear
about what the [ __ ] babe station is so
babe station was this channel
in the uk right and it would air at like
what like 11 30.
yeah yeah something it was literally
just like girls on a couch
like half naked and then they would
occasionally take off their bra but the
whole time
you wouldn't hear anything you'd just
hear like porn music but they were
calling someone you could call in and
talk to them
right and there's some good videos on
youtube people trolling them like that's
really funny but
as like a like a 14 year old i was like
damn
yeah it's basically chatterbaits before
on tv but but you can't hear what
they're saying
yeah because they're talking to someone
oh yeah occasionally they would let you
hear the audio
like yeah yeah this is what you could be
having but also 12 year old me i'm never
going to call them yeah yeah
but oh my god yeah cause i remember
after family guy it would air
so i would like to take up a family guy
episode just leave it running you know
yeah
yeah it's just nonchalantly yeah
i noticed actually that like uk tv at
night really
like holds no bards oh that was like
porn on so many channels because
i i because uh aki and i only recently
discovered
uh thanks to matzia about uh the show
naked attraction
um you know wait what's that what's that
yeah you showed that right to me
yeah naked attraction is basically this
this
show it's this show on uk television i
don't know what time it
is it's on channel 4 about like 9pm yeah
but basically it's this
is this it's this game show where a guy
or a girl would come onto the show
looking for a boyfriend or a girlfriend
right and
in the case with like say a a boy coming
on looking for a girlfriend
yeah what they would do is they would
show five different girls
but they would be butt naked
completely again like no mosaic
completely naked and what they would do
is they would start
from the down up so what they would do
is they would first show below the belt
right and then the guy would see
everything you can see oh oh and the
girl and then the guy
or girl would be like okay i like that
genitalia i don't like that genitalia
yeah and then
and then at that point just from looking
at like the genitalia
they have to be like uh no to this
person and
then they would go up to the tits and
then they would show the face and then
they would reveal the voice
and at the end when there's the last two
people remaining like the last two
contestants remaining
yeah the guy or girl who like originally
came onto the show they have to also
come out naked
oh and then and then as they're naked
they have to pick one of the two and
then they go on a date it's
it's really awful and i watched it and
aki and i were like
this is the most amazing show i've ever
seen yeah it's called uh
naked attraction naked attraction yeah
and there's clips of it on youtube
yeah how are they getting wet there's
entire seasons of it on youtube and i
don't understand how they're getting
away with it
like we get like i guarantee this
episode is going to get demonstrated
and yet whole episodes of naked
attraction can be on youtube and
youtube's like
well i get it's a tv show so i guess
it's okay yeah
but yeah i don't know i thought i was
gonna hate it at first because just from
the concept it sounds absolutely trashy
but it makes you like the worst person
ever oh you're like oh wow their feet
are slightly disformed
i'm going to have to it's not even their
feet it's like ah their pussy's a little
mangled up
oh god oh my god oh you have to say that
in front of the person i'm like
i would never be able to i don't i don't
think i have the self-confidence no
sure but these are like like just chill
people normal people and they go on and
and they're just like
i just wanted to spice it up a little
bit i'm like this they're spicing it up
and it's getting naked in front of the
entire country there's an infantry i'm
like is it really worth it for the 15
minutes of fame if you have to
show your naked body yeah yeah they show
you a little bit of the date afterwards
and they're always it's so
awkward it's so awkward it's like hi
oh yeah you like it so yeah i i i hear
you how you think about
wins tower defense i mean i like bloons
like how'd you go on a day after you've
just commented on their like weirdly
shaped penis
yeah exactly my favorite though is like
when
they do finally pick a winner right and
it's that awkward hug
oh they do an awkward they're doing an
awkward hug to the person
but it's so funny how like how how back
both of their like
those yeah
and the host is just watching and it's
like all right she's a christmas host in
the uk it's what's that woman she does
all the channel 4 shows
uh you she's a big brother oh davina
mccool
yeah davina mccoy yeah yeah so and she's
a really big name in the uk
i think she's a good host it's kind of
yeah that you know kind of got relegated
to the c team
i didn't know i didn't know she did big
brother but now i know that that totally
makes sense yeah
yeah going back to visual novels though
we got very of sidetracked
what was like the first visual novel
that you played then
that you would consider not going
through your trashy aerogay
teenager phase oh my god this is hentai
i think
the first one i played knowing exactly
what it was and enjoying the [ __ ] out of
it was
canon canon yeah because
i think it was weird right i kind of
discovered the canon visual novel
after i watched air right and what is
this stuff by the way okay
so no idea it's it's it's from the same
guy from the same people
i know that yeah so before clan ad
visual arts made
a number of games one of them being air
which uh
i watched the anime of and i first
discovered what visual arts is and i was
like oh i want to see oh this is based
off a game
i couldn't find i remember i couldn't
find the air visual novel anyway
but i found canon which is the first
game that they ever made
so i played canon and of course if you
know the story of canon i cried like a
[ __ ]
obviously yeah i was like the first time
in my life i was like
wow visual novels are really [ __ ]
long
because canon not only has like seven
different
endings but just to get to one ending it
takes about 30 hours
almost like a book it is yeah it's like
reading
seven different books at once that's how
they get you man i meet people who play
the same visual novel over and over
again and i'm like what's wrong with you
i mean i did that
go outside you've got to get all the
room go and do something productive dude
i play i want to play
eight hours of league of legends be
happy dude i played the clan visual
novel as well
just to get to the true ending it takes
like 200 hours oh my god but
you did that yeah because i was so
because i was so invested in the story
because once you get in
that's the thing with the secret vision
what do you when i play yeah
uh 15. how the [ __ ] do you have the
patience for that that's the 15th
because i
because because i used to read a lot of
books because you find time
you you i think what do you do as a 15
year old as a 15 year old like 200 hours
means nothing halo just came out i think
for me
like it's i didn't want to be like this
normie scum who played halo
i wanted to be a different boy i wanted
to embrace my weeabro there was nothing
better than pissing your friends off at
school by like destroying all their [ __ ]
like shooting them i mean
yeah i mean i would do that at school
but then i would come home and be like
you know what
i miss you nagisa i want to know what
happens to you baby
okay i had friends in my friend group
who we would always play xbox together
but there's always that one friend we
were great friends with
never hear from when he goes home and
you were that i was that kid
because i was in my room just like
continuously pressing space bars i'm
playing clan
oh my god because they're so good [ __ ]
check out this game play
yeah click click and then after and then
halfway through planet i realized the
auto function so i didn't even have to
click anything i was just like
i was just sitting but it was like
watching a movie i was like hell yeah
dude let's go it's just like
watching a movie with extra words i
don't think i'd be able to play a visual
novel like that now though no no because
unfortunately
it's like watching anime nowadays right
right you can't watch an anime that's
over like 13 episodes without having to
fully commit
right and it's unfortunate because like
especially in the last couple of years i
know there's been some [ __ ] amazing
visual novels that have come out which
i know if i put the time in i would
[ __ ] love yeah but
it's just unfortunate now that a lot of
these take like 100 plus hours and i
know i would have
no time sounds like hell to me this
sounds like that's a question to you
did you not play doki doki when that
came out nice you missed the doki doki
cross i just didn't i saw it and i was
like
cool girl kills herself everyone's happy
about it doki doki though i would
recommend because it's only like
five one right yeah yeah it's like a
good
gateway one which is because when that
blew up i just had
undertale flashbacks on youtube when
that yeah it was like because it was
that kind of audience that was getting
attracted to it
and i'm like people are only attracted
to this because this is the first time
they're seeing anything remotely
gorgeous yeah
like that's it i guarantee yeah exactly
like i'm sure there's way better visual
novels than doki doki right yeah oh
hundreds oh yeah right right exactly
but to them it was like the first time
that they were playing it's like a
visual novel
that was also like kind of mind trippy
and i'm like you guys clearly haven't
played saiyan utah because that's what i
[ __ ] you up i was about to say i think
like a good
i don't know a good gateway and not good
gateway visual novel is cyano utah yeah
because that's the vision of all that
just hits the ground running you know
what i mean like it has a
really interesting concept yeah but it
is [ __ ] up
so this is a visual novel written by
genna rabuchi who is the same guy who
wrote madoka magica fade
zero uh psycho pass and the concept
is about this guy i think he wakes up
and then i think he waits
yeah i can't remember the exact
beginning because the concept is
there's just there's just this guy who
who i think
you know he all he sees is just this
hellish landscape
okay like it's it's it's like grotesque
like there are like intestines america
i'm sorry i'm gonna get killed for that
there's just like intestines on the
walls and just like
veins popping out it's very generic yeah
it's like this
it's like a scene from silent hills or
something like some of the most hellish
scenes from silent hills
um and the only thing that's normal is
this like one
little lolly that's just like she's the
only
normal thing in this headless landscape
because every like every other person
is just like a it's just this like also
hellish blob that he can't understand
so the only thing he the only person he
can communicate with
is this lolly and then that to me just
drew me in
immediately right because it was like
it's cool because it was like yeah
what's going on damn why
why is it this way and like the the way
that's that's what i look for in a
vision of it because a lot of visual a
lot of the problems i see with a lot of
vision novels doki doki included
is that the beginning's like very
similar where she's like huh here's a
high school
normal setting here's his all the
characters and you know it
it takes that time to get invested in
the story right once you do it's [ __ ]
great yeah
but sayonara uta if you can handle a bit
if
if you're not squeamish then uh and you
know you can handle a bit more
you know your stomach's a bit stronger
if you can get past the gore sano does a
fantastic visual noise
it's a great story great characters
everything about is awesome hey guys
this episode of the trash taste podcast
is proudly sponsored by cd
japan cd japan is the best place to
order japanese cds dvds blu-rays and
collectibles they offer the widest
variety of major and independent j-rock
and j-pop music that you can find
anywhere not only are they an e-commerce
site they also have a proxy shipping
service that is easily their most
popular offering so basically to explain
proxy shipping
if there's certain items that you can
only get if you're in japan
like for example we recently bought a
lot of jojo merch that you could
that you could only get in japan do you
want to explain what you've bought from
japan
oh god i mean we have the the watch that
joey's wear
hell yeah let's say if you wanted those
sweet jojo suits that i posted on my
twitter you couldn't get that unless you
live in japan but if there was a proxy
service you'd be able to get a hold of
those yeah so all you need to do is give
them the link to whatever product you
want and they will buy it and ship it
for you straight to wherever you live
and the good thing is in case you didn't
get any of that then on the website as
well they give you a step-by-step guide
on how proxy services work so you
fully understand how to get the
necessary equipment and
much that you're looking for so
basically if you see anything
on our shelves that you can find online
that might not be
available on that website then you can
use the proxy shipping service
we've also heard that their customer
service is extraordinary and it's one of
the aspects that they care most about
off the service
and of course with the recent events
that have been going on in the world
they've also done a really good job to
keep everything up to date for all of
the customers including all of their
social media and of course
the aforementioned customer service so
you can be sure that you're in some
pretty good hands
there's tons of different delivery
methods on the website such as dhl
fedex so no matter what you order you
can guarantee that you will get it
safely and in one piece and no matter
where you live as well they will make
sure your item gets to you let's see
what jojo's stuff they got i mean just
on the side oh they have the jorno pen
oh yeah they do look at that me and
connor have uh yeah i have this one i
also have like three knock-offs oh wait
no i have the bucharati pants i have the
drum actually
yeah it's really cool it works as a
figurine and it works as a pen you never
would never have
you never use it as a pen it's an
awkward pen yeah you imagine buying this
and being
like i'm gonna use this but it is cool
this is cool
if you want something like that it's
available on cd japan cool
oh you can get the entirety of the manga
in japanese
crusaders 20 bucks for the entirety of
stardust
crusaders bro bro well this is why you
need to learn japanese so you
can buy you can buy manga whatever and
read it
for that cheap that's [ __ ] crazy you
can get the first volume of steel ball
run for
six dollars six dollars oh my god that's
so cool let's see let's see what figures
they have
oh date alive oh yeah the kurumi
tokusaki china dress version
whoa oh that looks [ __ ] nice though
look at that dude that's hot
that's hot that's hot that's a lot of
damage
the important part right there hell yeah
what else they got
is that kagi osama oh i saw that
actually yeah wait enhanced
enhanced enhancements damn it where we
go we lost we lost it we lost her
where did she go so again if you want to
go and check out some japan only stuff
that you might not be able to get
from your country then cdjapan.com is
the best place to get it so again
thank you to cdj japan for sponsoring
today's episode back to the video okay
i'm hearing all about these great visual
novels and they sound crazy
but i don't know if i'm just a person
who's never going to get into visual
novels because of how i am like i
is is danganronpa a visual novel because
i felt like
i felt like it was yeah okay because
that's that [ __ ] dragged on
danganronpa is is kind of half
visual novel half mystery game
because it's visual novel in the aspect
of when you're
going through the story elements of it's
100 visual novel yeah like in the way it
looks and the way it presents the story
but
when it comes to the actual murder
mysteries you have to solve there's a
bit of
exploration that happens and the whole
part of when you go to the actual trial
that's a whole game in and of itself
yeah that's true i mean i
just got i remember being so frustrated
playing that i don't know why which one
did you play though the first one
okay i don't play with this is it bad
the second one is by far
i thought everyone said like the third
one's the worst the third one is the
worst but
first one's not great either the first
one i i didn't i wasn't a huge fan of
the
i played all three first one was okay
yeah the second one though is by far the
most optimized than best in terms of
like game playing so the story in terms
of characters
everything yeah and then the third one
they just they dropped the ball dude i'm
so disappointed
they bombed that so [ __ ] hard it was
the ending to the third one which i was
just like
you made me sit through three whole
games of this [ __ ] and that's how you
end it
[ __ ] you if the if you had to like pitch
it to me to get me into visual novels as
i'm sure there are some viewers at home
how would you do that because like as
somebody who's never experienced visual
novel and doesn't really think that
he'll like it i mean do you like books
it's been a while since i've ever well
there's your first
slide there's our first problem the
problem is with the books is that i
never seek them out but every time i've
read a book i've had a great time
yeah okay then that might just be the
case with visual novels or maybe all you
need
is just that one visual novel that you
can relate to yeah and because you know
that
the pool of visual novels is so deep
what's like some beginner
recommendations for
visual novels that like everyone must
honestly doki doki really
yeah doki doki is a great like it's it's
it's just a great starter one because
it's so short and
if you can get through like the the
worst part of doki doki unfortunately is
like the first half where it's just how
it normally is
yeah it's just setting up the scene and
everything um but
like the halfway point hits and it's
like oh oh this is this has got a lot of
interest
in defense of doki doki do the reason
why the first half is so boring is
because it's parodying visual novels
yeah yeah
so knowing that if you go into doki doki
with that mindset then the first half is
a little more bearable
but the thing is if you're not
interested in the actual the problem
with visual novels is if you're not
invested in the story
you're not gonna enjoy it no matter how
flashy or good it is
yeah right and that's the unfortunate
thing is that so many visual novels get
passed under the rug because
too many people are just too lazy to get
into the story yeah yeah exactly
yeah this guy i hate story and video
okay then here's here's a question to
you then uh what are like
some visual novel adaptations for anime
that you've just really enjoyed that's a
good question
have you watched a lot i think i have
maybe you have watched a lot and you
just didn't
you know because i i can't remember the
top my ad which one okay so some of them
might be steins gates
i like steins gate a lot but that felt
like a visual novel when i was watching
yeah i mean there's lots of moments
where they weren't afraid to like
be boring yeah like okay not be boring
but they weren't afraid to let you sit
with mundane situations it's a very slow
character development amazing anime
though yeah like i [ __ ] loved that
and it's an amazing yeah yeah because i
remember i hadn't had the game on 360.
i just never played it right right i
don't know why i never played it i think
i bought i watched the anime i thought
whoa
i want to play this i bought it never
played it because i was like
and there's also like the fate franchise
a lot of that
every faith series i've watched uh ex i
didn't watch the new ones because they
were based on that i mean there's a lot
of faces
heavens feel i don't watch having fuel i
watched i love fate stay night and fade
zero are some of my favorite uh
unlimited blade works yeah some of my
favorite
well that's all just the fader no i know
it is but but then
you know you want to get into fate and
you see the [ __ ]
chart of like the fate law
and you're like wait there's how many
sabres i don't want this many sabers
this is true it was just type moon being
like let's make this universe just
it's so difficult so you watch the anime
and you think
this is a little confusing but it makes
sense i like this
and then you actually go and look what
fate is and you're like this is a
dumpster fire
i feel like the biggest enemy against
pete getting people getting into fate
is ironically the fate fandom itself oh
no um because okay here's the thing i'm
like
i don't like i have one like one of the
most popular fake videos which is just
me
parodying how how to unlike a newcomer
trying to understand the fate series
yeah yeah
and like to me good video as someone who
like really likes fate
it's really not that hard to get into
you watch unlimited blade works you
watch phase zero it doesn't matter which
one
you watch either one they're both
amazing yeah yeah they can be enjoyed by
themselves and then
from there you just you just you just
take it from that's exactly what navi
told me when i was trying to get into
the fate
series he was like i was like okay i can
trust your opinion because you've been
with fate from the very beginning until
now
what how do i get into it and he was
just like watch fate zero
watch fake unlimited blade works and you
all understand 95 percent of the law and
the rest is just about
really yeah but like but like the
problem is
the like collect the fake fandom as a
collective just can't seem to [ __ ]
agree on it
because there's like there's i i [ __ ]
lost lost it because there was this
reddit thread recently
on like our anime and someone had made
uh i think the title of the
thread was i made an easy to follow
guide on how to get into fates
right and the ultimate clickbait and
it was i i [ __ ] burst out laughing
when i saw like 800 upvotes
700 comments and i'm just like oh oh boy
here we [ __ ] go oh my god i'm
i'm gonna i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
popcorn and i remember like one one of
the one of the top
one of the top comments was just like oh
yeah just watch fate zero it doesn't
really [ __ ] matter face zero is good
and like the next comment is but you're
not gonna understand x if you watch
phase zero
i'm just like oh my god like
how does how i can't imagine how it
looks for a newcomer because it looks
like a [ __ ] right
yeah it does i mean i watched fate zero
first
and i thought it was like a classic
right i thought it's a great show i mean
i can re-watch faith zero
yeah yeah i i don't know i do you get do
you get put off by shows if the fan base
is toxic or [ __ ] i mean it's
because i don't i'm just like [ __ ] you
i'm gonna watch the show make my own
opinion
yeah it's weird right because i remember
fate the fake fandom used to be a lot
more toxic
right because they used to be more toxic
oh no definitely there's there was like
there was this phase right
where if you recommended people to start
fate with fate zero
when that first came out then then there
would be people in the fake family who
were just like how
dare you how dare you not just recommend
the original visual novels
like it was like if you're not willing
to sit through a two through 100 hour
visual novel then why are you even
enjoying this franchise
you know what i mean and now god now
it's evolved a bit now it's like okay
people just want other people to get
into fate
but you now they just don't know how to
agree on one specific way to get into
face right
and it's the problem because it's a
problem of fate being a visual novel
adaptation
because there is there is no perfect
adaptation of fate state night because
if if you think about it logically
like you if you think about something
like the monogatari series easy
you start you start with release order
all right so you start with bakimonogate
because that came out first you know
but the problem with fate is that
chronologically the first
released adaptation of the fate
franchise
is just [ __ ] right because it was it was
a studio
the face day night yeah face day nights
adapted by studio dean
right so that that basically adapted the
the first route of the fate visual novel
the fate state night vision novel right
but it's it's also like a really hard
starting point for newbies to get into
fate because it's like it's
it's just it's just [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] you
can't recommend in this day and age so
what you would have to recommend is
probably unlimited yeah unlimited blade
works
which is the second route but then you
know
but then people skip over the like
entire first route which is the fate
stay night route so it's it's
it's complicated because of the way the
visual novel
is laid out i i hope i genuinely thought
fate stay night
and fate stay uh unlimited blade works
was just a remake
of fate stay night yeah you'd think so
right is it not no
no no okay completely different things i
think from my understanding correct me
if i'm wrong okay
fate stay night unlimited blade works
and heaven's feel are just different
endings to fate stay night yeah okay so
i feel like this is how
nasa must feel trying
is complicated like no no it's okay so
yeah there there are like three roots in
in the original face oh my god i'm doing
the [ __ ] i'm doing the meme now
this is the short version what happened
to numbers not number [ __ ] anymore
it's because of the ways way visual
novels are laid out with different roots
right so you think of something like
clan ad or something where
like a different route you get a
different girl or like you know that's
that's like a pokemon women are like
collect them so in fate it's like every
route is completely different but it
starts
at the same starting point okay if that
makes sense
um so technically a notepad like do i
need to like write this [ __ ]
they all start at the same starting
point but that's not made apparent in
the anime adaptations no no
i [ __ ] hate it which is why you would
which is why you would think that
unlimited blade works and fate
stay night and fate zero and heavens
feel are completely different games
yeah but in retrospect they all are the
same dude sometimes i feel like i'm the
only [ __ ] who just doesn't give a
[ __ ] about half this [ __ ] because like
everyone seems to know and then i'm
sitting there like i just want to
just click trust me it took me [ __ ]
forever to understand
one percent of the money most people
like me or like you guys
because i i don't know i feel like i'm
in the minority i've been here since the
beginning so you guys
probably don't remember that there's
been two unlimited blade works
adaptation
i did not know that wait wait both by
you photo table or
no one like studio dean did face day
night then i think they did
uh unlimited blade works movie as well
i'm serious yeah yeah and then you
football came along and was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] we're starting over at
fade zero and then
and then they were like okay [ __ ] okay
we've done phase zero
[ __ ] face day night let's go to
unlimited blade works and then
adapt heaven's field i only cause i only
remember that there was two fate stay
nights
yeah and then it was the there was the
studio
this is too much and the ufo table was
like hold my beard let's do a better
adaptation and then it was just all from
there but i didn't
i didn't know about the second unlimited
yeah and this is just the
i'm making fate looks so [ __ ] bad now
it is
and we're not even mentioning all the
[ __ ] stuff like like
this is just the main timeline canon as
well
just watch fate zero and then if you
like it come on honestly honestly from
what i've heard
if you want to get into fate just watch
fade zero and unlimited zero is a great
[ __ ] show and it's
you could watch it on its own you don't
need to have a college degree or a phd
to understand what the [ __ ] is going on
just watch it
if you like all the characters you know
it's [ __ ] great hey watch monogatari
it's less complicated
yeah so is pokemon like what are we
recommending that
facebook's a lot of fun i mean you get
into it for the good story and then
you're like man
i got into it because i was doing a fan
dub okay oh yeah
someone else's fan dub of it oh okay i
think i was playing like
how the hell do you do in a breached of
the fate series it wasn't the british it
was a handout i know but like just the
hypothetical question has anyone done an
approach of this yeah no people have
done in the bridge over the philippines
the bridge of everything yeah how do you
abridge something that complicated
i mean it's you can just abridge a
certain show but like
like having to explain the entire
franchise
i mean that's uh that's that's that's an
undertaking i wanna i wanna fate
abridged where the entire bridge is just
them explaining the fate law
i don't know i'm actually doing a video
on that spoilers
i've actually been working on that for
like over a month
of course you have like it's that was
not a scripted bit i'm just letting you
know
promoting his future content yeah yeah
yeah it's it's probably not gonna be
held by the time this this
this like this episode comes out but uh
i i don't know it's
there's different because the fade the
fake franchise is so wide right but
it's like just this rabbit hole that you
can just sink in and there will always
feel like we found a trap talking about
it here yeah yeah yeah
but that's the thing like if if you just
want to enjoy fate zero and
unlimited blade works you can you can
just that's what i did yeah
yeah what what did you think of them
then i loved them both individually i
felt very satisfied and i felt that
i'm okay not having more i'm like i was
i
saw the the you know it's like you
finish it
and then you walk outside and you see
the rest of the world on fire and you're
like no
not today are you gonna watch heaven's
feel then uh i thought
someone told me that that was just based
on the gacha game no
that's that's that's fake grounder and
order yeah oh is that is that an anime
series as well yeah yeah there's a fake
grand old anime
and then there's also to make it more
confusing the fake grand order anime
adapts
the like i think like the like one of
the later chapters
in the fake grand order gacha game so it
doesn't even start at the beginning
why why are they doing this you know i'm
type moon dude
like i i i wanna watch more because i
enjoyed
what i watched but at the same time it
just seems like i'm gonna be watching it
thinking
that's the thing it's like i'm scared to
start watching the heavens feel movies
as much as i want to yeah
because i'm just like oh god do i have
to like [ __ ] i'm revised it's gonna
be paranoid
i'm gonna be watching thinking like [ __ ]
did i have to do research like [ __ ] i
just wanted to like
watch something you know like it's it's
very daunting but it's really not that
complicated because
says you say that you say that you
literally went on a ten minute run about
how
much [ __ ] mess this is i mean it's
not that complicated
look you can enjoy heaven's feel if
you've like watched fate zero and ubw
that's that's that's that's the end all
because enjoy a lot of things if you
talk to yourself
you you know he's a veteran when he
calls unlimited blade worst ubw
so it's too long ubw you know you know
what i mean right he comes up so much in
his daily vocabulary
but he has to shorten unlimited
bladeboards
fellow fake fans i tried okay i i i i i
tried my [ __ ] hardest thank you
if i find i'm not falling for your trap
today not today i
i'm i'm happy not having i will sink
that time into a visual novel before i
try and get into the thing
okay do people just like not watch shows
and then just think okay i'm done
i've had enough of this show you know
that's how i felt with faith well yeah
but i mean some people just uh get so
invested in the characters that they
just want to go
further beyond right who liked sabres so
much that we had this many sabers why
wasn't one saber okay am i am i mistaken
with being happy i don't know man
you should ask his people okay okay i i
like what's wrong with one saver that's
right
why why okay but not enough okay okay
here's the thing right i didn't get it
until i started playing fake grand order
and then
and then i totally get it because save
like i don't care too much
about saber but rin you know rin's my
girl
so oh oh i know yeah from from
yeah yeah so so whenever like there's uh
how many rings are there i mean there's
there's no the fact that there's not a
clear answer this question is [ __ ] up
there's there's not as many
rings as there are sabers
for example like getting ishtar for
example i'm like i i need to get
every time there's a character that kind
of resembles rin i'm like
well i'm not i'm not gonna lie the first
time i saw ishtar i was like oh is that
rin
you know i i hear this [ __ ] and all i
think of like man this sounds like
it's nearing kingdom hearts level of
[ __ ]
oh no i i i totally
because this is we're just talking about
the series we haven't gotten into fate
law
we're not getting into that
i don't like all this like apocrypha and
like
a colleague and stuff yeah you know you
know being around anime fans here you
just hear
these words like apoc apocrypha whatever
i hear that [ __ ] so much
i don't know what it means i don't know
i don't want to know what it means i
don't know what it means either but i
know it's just the spin off
so much all i know is that apocrypha and
and callidalia are spin-offs
but there's spin-offs that also add to
the law it's time to i mean
okay
we're not getting into clean okay so to
start off my lecture today
things that i didn't get before let's go
back to that oh my god
no i feel like two minutes say your
piece okay just watch phase zero watch
watch unlimited blade works and then
that's that's like the main line
timeline so you can enjoy
heaven's feel and then if you want to
enjoy more of the fake franchise you can
because
none of it's technically cannon even
though it is but i'm not going to get
into that
just watch just just watch the main
timeline shows and that's
that's me that's that's it that's it you
say watch the main timeline shows but at
this point we don't know what the main
timeline shows
up i'm convinced people are like fate
also like [ __ ] and ball torture
they want to die the one thing about
fate that i want to say is that i
couldn't
[ __ ] believe when i asked the same
question
to navi my friend who's like heavenly to
fate about saber i was like why are
there so many sabers
and you know what he said to me he's
like saber the class will save her the
character
and i mean what do you mean
i mean like i mean i mean saber and he's
like yeah which one
i'm like what do you mean what do you
mean which one he's like because there's
saber the class
yeah and then there's the character
character i know that i know
i know that because like there's she is
the saber class yeah
they say that like the rider right like
the assassins yeah yeah class
but then he yeah but then he was like
saber closest every character i'm like
what
saber the one called saver what which
one is it
and at that point i was like okay i
don't think i'll ever be able to get
into this series
so bottom line uh when it comes to
visual novels
maybe maybe skip out on faith unless
you're like very committed i'm convinced
right
if if fate didn't exist the world would
be 100 more productive
we would have cured every known disease
on the planet
these people are too busy making [ __ ]
timeline charts yeah type moon would
actually be like a cancer institute
right yeah
honestly if we redirected that mental
resource into doing something productive
we would have there would be no poverty
poverty would be ended
but instead we wanted a hundred sabres
that's what we went for
it's because we just want to collect the
waifu's okay we just
we just want a slightly different
variation of the same character so
so they could they could like sell us to
like roll another like 100 rolls on the
gotcha
and then we can be like yeah i have
another saber i have everything i want
oh wait
they released another saber oh okay
okay i see i see this is just like that
you know like there's memes where it's
like the [ __ ]
the the business meeting with the
executives and they're like what do the
people want
they really like it seems like gentlemen
they really enjoy
saber and someone's like saber two saber
two
and it's like three sabers saber two but
it's not
the saber if if saber's so good why
isn't there a saber too
and the the executive's like we got your
back super saver
saber
those are two different characters at
this point type moon
has to be [ __ ] with us right like i i
i'm i'm ready for them i'm ready for
type moon to just come out
and just like pulling under hideout you
just mean like yeah all of that
has no meaning i just wanted to [ __ ]
with you i'm going insane
listening to god trying to explain this
[ __ ] to me i want to have an episode
where i
hate this i just like spent an hour
explaining fate law to you guys
it's but going back to visual novels
right
that we would recommend to beginners aka
not
[ __ ] face like one pain to another
okay other than other than doki doki
literature club what's like another
visual novel that you would recommend to
connor undertale
god undertale i don't know because there
are none
psych okay question would you recommend
carlos shojo
shoujo also has like act one is it it
takes
it takes reading through act one to get
really invested into kind of a shojo
kind of show just great by the way yeah
um but there's like a 10 million sabers
in that as well
there isn't there isn't 70 cuddlers
unfortunately kind of a shojo actually
has a
very very interesting backstory okay um
because xiaomi on it
no because i i mean i feel like the
backstory is almost as interesting as
the visual novel itself i don't want to
say too much because i'm also working on
a visual
visual uh on a video on it but it's it's
it's a visual novel
that basically originated from 4chan and
can you believe something good actually
came out of fortnite no no no no
so it's like a dating simulator with
crippled girls
from 4chan and you say that and you're
like i don't know about that
i don't know about this jw's be quaking
yeah but like
it's it's one of the most like wholesome
kind of
inspirational stories about how these
disabled girls like really
just are just normal people and just
like like how they deal with their
disabilities that sounds good yeah it's
great it's fantastic it's it's a it's
actually a really really good visual
novel and if
like how much patience do you have
though because i i i've seen you gaming
right
if you're not doing something within the
first five seconds if you're not like
head shotting
the headshot no scope
in the first 10 seconds i can't i have i
have a i have an amount that i can i can
like power up in myself but is it enough
to go through the first chapter of
cuddle shoujo why is it that bad
it's a it's a bit of a it's not bad it's
not it's a bit of a how long is the
first chapter
oh that's a good question i can't i
can't remember i can't hear how fast
it depends how fast you reach an hour or
more i'd say like an hour
that's a lot of time or two maybe yeah
holy [ __ ] that was that's the same with
doki doki because like it takes an hour
or two to get through the first half but
mind you unlike doki doki which is about
a
six to seven hour game carlos shojo is
about 30 to 40 hours
that's fine so compared to that an hour
is not too bad until it starts
honestly i i do think sayana uta would
be really really good for someone
someone like you because i know you can
handle that [ __ ] and that was something
that hooked me instantly
maybe i'll stream am i a live stream is
it a game i can stream no it's banned on
twitch oh geez
it was the first visual novel that was
banned on twitch because of course
gennarovich be out here just being like
i'm not making anything that's fairly
friendly
i'm here to traumatize everybody that
plays my [ __ ]
no because it it's it's a story it's
it's a vision novel that doesn't have
that you know entry period it just it
has a very interesting concept
and it just kind of hooks you right away
and for me i remember just reading cyano
uta and i read it all in like one
sitting because i just wanted to know
immediately what happens next like there
was there was no break from me
starting it to finishing it um in terms
of like
visual novel type games i don't know
like
okay here's the thing do you would you
count the persona series as like a
visual novel
with a lot of gameplay in it oh that
seems like an rpg to me it
okay the thing with the persona series
is that it's really interesting because
yes it is a jrpg
but a whole lot of the jrpg
element and like how you play the jrpg
element of that game is dependent on the
visual novel side of the game yeah
because what what
what the persona series did which i
think is [ __ ] genius is that
they made you the way that they made you
sit through the story
of persona and it's a long story if
you've played any persona game right
yeah
the genius way that they made you sit
through is that by sitting through it
and
physically interacting with certain
characters in certain ways
it changes how strong you become in the
jrpg element
yeah so what you do is you form at least
in persona 5
what you do is you you by talking to
certain characters and befriending them
and like going out to do these like
normal everyday things
yeah you would level up your different
abilities and those abilities then get
directly reflected in the jrpg elements
so the more you're involved in the story
the easier time you will have in the
jrpg elements and what that forces you
to do is that not only
is it interesting because it's like
you're playing two different games at
once but
you are literally forced to sit through
the story yeah yeah so
everybody who plays it enjoys the story
so like if you imagine like a gotcha
game right
so in every gacha game there's like the
gameplay element and then there's the
gatch element
well i played uh fire emblem three
houses right and that had a lot of
story building which i found so boring
oh you found that boring yeah i found it
really boring but i would just skip
whenever they start talking i'm like bbb
but the thing is but the thing is fire
emblem three houses kind of did the same
thing
where you doing everyday things around
the campus would affect you in battle i
mean i liked
fire emblem three houses right i enjoyed
what i did but
i i for s whatever reason man the moment
i see text pop on my screen i'm like
i'm like you are in the way of my game
you are so monkey bro
you got that [ __ ] monkey i don't know
what happened to me in the womb but like
i i can't pay attention to story and
games like i
i'm sure there's one or two people out
there who can can sympathize with me but
the moment story comes on any video game
i'm like where's the skip button where
is it really
i can't i can't pay attention what's
what's your favorite story in a video
game then
[Music]
trick question has there ever been one
bro i need to like really go deep in my
memory
i remember the only game that i think i
watched the cutscenes and i think i was
like 15.
i don't even know why i played this game
it's called blue dragon it was a jrpg
never weird games probably two people in
the comments who like i know what that
is
it's like that it's a jlp comment below
if you play blue dragon
it was it was just seemed like a dragon
quest knockoff
but i didn't know what dragon quest was
at the time but i watched dragon quest
afterwards and i was like
wait a second this looks awfully like
that game i used to like
and you know it pains me every time but
when i go to press that skip button yeah
i don't know what it is like i is there
something wrong with me that i can't
enjoy story and video games
i mean i'm sure there's a because
maybe but like for me it's like i look
for a gameplay loop
not a not a story i'm like i'm like the
complete opposite
well no because you play you've played
league of legends you played it a fair
amount you played people like playing
right now in terms of like single-player
games yeah like i i
need a story i don't play single-player
games i mean you played
for example cuphead or something yeah
actually speedrun cuphead that was fun
but that was for the gameplay loop that
wasn't for
yeah yeah exactly like like i tried
playing cuphead i'm like why am i
playing cuphead
what is the narrative reason for me to
complete this game i just love running
gun games i
i i need a narrative reason and if you
need me to sit through like a two-hour
cut scene i'll [ __ ] do it
if it's if it's if it's a good if it's a
good story i'll [ __ ] do it
like the reason i loved doom 2016 so
much is
you literally start that game you smash
a skull open and you start shooting
i'm like that was like oh my god dude in
2016 is the epitome of like
like they made monkeys they made a game
for me
it was like gun enemies let's go
that was like exactly what i wanted i
just wanted a game that was like [ __ ]
the story let's just make a
like game play that is addictive right
yeah and so when i play
like you know what pisses me off to
death about jrpgs i love jrpgs but do
you the moment
the moment they start making the menu a
[ __ ] challenge is when i start i'm
like this is too much like
i love fire emblem three houses right
but there was times in that the menuing
was like half the gameplay
i'm the officer yeah yeah
you are playing the game on the main
menu yeah like okay you know like
i i go from i jump from multiplayer as a
game with multiplayer games like i've
been like
diamond and league of legends like five
years in a row yeah i started playing
tft recently
got to diamond one and that nearly
master tier if you know if you play
these games you know it's good [ __ ] i'm
a
big brain essentially playing valid now
with god sometimes yeah
it's a good game to csgo i played
overwatch got to master in that like i i
mean okay what's like your opinion on
like something like the metal gear solid
series then did you ever play
those games yeah i played your song i
like well because that's like hit very
heavily stuff yeah that's like a
that's like that's not vision of it
that's just cut scene enough
[Laughter]
like halo right halo i love halo i have
no idea what any of the stories are
about the moment
i remember like the halo story is great
yeah i remember there was a scene where
i play mass effect
no no no no no too much story for me i
remember
i remember halo right i remember they
like hyped it up the sad ending like i
mean
if you don't know that cortana you know
yeah but she comes back
sort of so doesn't cortana dies right i
remember everyone was hyping up dude
so sad so sad and i was playing my
friend and we were doing it together
yeah and the moment the cutscene
happened i [ __ ] skipped it
no no what are you doing like we need to
find out what happens i'm like why we
got to shoot things
oh this this is hurting me so much i
don't know man i just
i'm sure there's one am i in the
minority here uh
i don't know i feel like it's 50 50
right maybe or like seven maybe
maybe i don't know i don't know because
there must be a reason why the most
popular games are
like multiplayer games right yeah it
means they played by 11 year olds you
know that
monkey brain a monkey brain i mean the
the reason i got into games like league
and vitamin is just because
i could just get into it it's like it
was like a stress it's a 40 minute thing
that you
do and it's no more it's just it's just
like a it's it's like a different kind
of stress for even like animal crossing
for example but
you just you just get in a quick session
you get out you play as long as you want
it's a close loop you don't feel like
anything else like for single-payer
player experiences
i wish i i like to get invested in a
game
in the same way that i like to get
invested in an anime and like i i love
just i love that feeling of just
marathoning a show and just
getting started putting yourself into a
story and being able to like physically
interact with the story is so [ __ ]
cool yeah i think i ruined games for
myself
um during the xbox so is there literally
not a single game that you enjoyed the
story of
i cannot like i i enjoyed zelda breath
of the wild a fuckton but i don't know
like what i was doing did you i just
remember because when i the while it's
such a good story too
does it the moment we started talking to
npcs i'm like give me the bomb give me
the items
shut the [ __ ] up i need a potion breath
of the wild was the last game i played
where i got like
no matter what other game was out there
that i wanted to play it like you said
it sucked me in i loved that game yeah
that was because
i felt like the way they built the world
didn't require a story because the story
was the same [ __ ] we're used to it was
no
bad going back but but in my opinion the
the most genius thing about breath of
the wild is that yes
you could skip all of the dialogue and
still really [ __ ] enjoy it
that's why i loved it because it was
like it was like do your own thing it's
even more enjoyable when you actually
talk to the npcs and especially the ones
that are kind of just out in the open
not the ones that are in the towns and
just hearing what they say
it does such a good job at world
building
i'm serious you're laughing you're
laughing but the npc's like i l i listen
to all the npcs and i'm like okay i have
so much of a better understanding of
this wall
joey's like i'm on the visual novel
playthrough i'm hearing this and i'm
like wait you spoke to the mpc
yeah wait when like okay the thing i
hate the most right
is when games make you speak to npcs
i i hate that so much it depends on like
the game for me because if it's
a world i'm not invested in then i'm
like whatever this is this is
this is shitty but if it's like what i'm
super invested in i speak i'm that kind
of person just speaks to everyone
because i want to get as much content as
i can out of this game yeah exactly and
i remember speaking to you and you're
like i can't enjoy a game if i if i'm
not making someone else's day
be worse
okay okay i said that to you as a joke
but that's kind of true right
like there's just something that like to
me
and maybe this is again coming back to
the episode where we spoke about chess
right like
to me gaming has always been a thing of
like it's like a
thing where i can i can learn a skill i
can get better at that skill and then i
can beat others
yeah right and like you know sometimes
you play a game of league of legends
and it feels like you're playing the
piano like it feels like you're just
crushing them
but then when you when you get when you
lose it's not a good feeling
but yeah i i want to play a game and i
want to beat other people half the time
he wants to make someone else's day
worse yeah
that's that's how he gets enjoyment
exactly like as well like
if i play league of legends i can't play
normal games like
like i need to play a ranked game
because i know that people will will
give a [ __ ]
because if people aren't giving a [ __ ]
no one's invested right if i if i
[ __ ]
die a ton no one gives a [ __ ] in a
normal i mean they do but i don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah but if i die in a ranked game i'm
like [ __ ] i think that's why i've never
gone into pvp games
really just because i've never given a
[ __ ] really yeah that's probably why
i can't like i don't give a [ __ ] do you
not like refining a skill like getting
good at something
and like that's not what i play games
for i mean that's what i do
i play games for for [ __ ] escapism
right but then i guess my form of
escapism is
learning the skill and having that
gameplay loop of doing it over and over
again and then going against other
people
no i don't have that because i don't
give it because like in my opinion the
reason why i love jrpgs is because
there are no bragging rights with jrpgs
by finishing a jrpg it's not like
yeah i beat this game like that's why i
beat persona 5 like five times
it's not because i wanted to brag to
people that have been to five times but
because i wanted to see the route
but you just bragged about i'm joking
yeah i just did it
but no it's not it's not for bragging
rights i don't do it for that and i
don't do it to
feel superior or anything i just do it
because to me i guess
gaming for me the way that it's been a
an escape is that
i get to sink myself because i'm i'm i
need to be challenged constantly
yeah and when a game doesn't challenge
me in like either mechanical skill or
like mentally
like i'm just not invested because i'm
like it's not challenging me i need
something to challenge i mean this is
why i like play instruments right
so that i could get that side of my
brain focused yeah right yeah yeah
but then i guess we're all different
right like for me
i think maybe escapism and you do have
that part of you want to challenge
yourself but it's it's satisfied by just
learning
an instrument or playing an instrument
but for me it's like i think it's way
too consuming for me
like i'm way too competitive like i was
that one [ __ ] in school who turned
everything into the olympics
i was like there was always that one guy
yeah we're doing a light jog
oh oh we're doing a light jogger and
then i would [ __ ] sprint right
yeah i remember like okay if this
doesn't explain how like competitive i
am i don't know what will in school
when we used to do long distance running
i was terrible at long distance running
okay but you bet every single time we
did it i made myself throw up i was so
desperate
i was so desperate to win the long
distance running that i would literally
every single time we ran i would push
myself into the point of throwing up
because i wouldn't stop i wouldn't stop
right you don't miss
and i remember it literally became a
joke at some point that every like
because every year you would do a school
thing
yeah yeah yeah and i remember i would do
the 400 meters and i would not stop
sprinting
the whole time and i would literally get
to that i would sprint the whole hot 400
meters to win
i would stop and i would just go
because because i was pushing myself way
beyond what was needed
yeah because in my head it was
embarrassing to lose
i mean like i get people okay and before
anyone thinks wow man connor your
parents must have raised you in a way
that made you think but no
dude my parents were like yo connor calm
the [ __ ] like my parents were like where
did this come from because we're not
like
that's interesting you say that though
because then now i'm wondering
why you're so heavily into arc nights
because nights is a pve game not a pvp
game but but it's still got i i think i
know because it's still got like
challenges in there
and arc nights is the worst [ __ ] like
combo for you because it's a game that
you can't win
unless you spend more money yeah and
then even if you spend more money
you still can't win and and and there's
a whole bit of enjoyment by following
the story i didn't follow the story
i mean you know i've you know i've
leveled 95 and arc nights but now that
i've beaten all of episode six and done
all the challenge modes i kind of woke
up the other day and i'm like
i don't know what have i got to do i've
done it i've done it
i've done it i'm in the end i've
completed
the arc but like that's the thing right
and then
i think i also destroyed any chance i
had of liking story games because
when achievements were a thing on xbox
360. yeah you bet i was that [ __ ] who
was like i'm going to want
you know you're the achievement hunter
yeah 100 a game
yeah and i i got way too into some games
and i remember i got so
frustrated with jrpgs because i would
just buy any game but it was due to
research which games were easiest to get
an achievement i didn't do that i just
bought a game and i would complete it
but [ __ ] jrpgs man they had the worst
achievements they were like collect
every one of this item
and then you would go to the guide and
be like oh well seven of these items you
can only get
at that time and if you didn't get it at
that time sorry kid you got to restart
the game
and i'm like i hate you who did this i
hate you so so much
i think that was a saving grace for me
that i never owned like an xbox 360 or a
playstation like i never i never
played on a console that had
achievements i was always just a
nintendo kid so it was literally just
you versus the game yeah i wish i did
that because
i remember i got an xbox one and one day
i was like why am i
why am i getting these achievements
i can perfect this skill to get all of
the achievements oh
dude okay now and it's on it's
challenging this is a challenge
and then i look back at all the [ __ ] i
did like i beat the lost video game
the [ __ ] lost video game and i
remember
that even i didn't even know there was a
lot even my 15 year old self could tell
this video game was not a video game
like this was
garbage dude and and i beat it just to
get that 1 000 and she i hated that game
yeah actually question to you then do
you kind of like
gamify life sometimes like dude you know
what's weird okay that's a good question
yeah
do you want to explain what you're going
to go with the rest of certified no
because like basically
you know sometimes i do see our job
youtube as it's kind of like a game
right because
because they [ __ ] gamified this you
get achievements you get numbers
you got your rivals you know you do a
good video it gives you a pat on the
back it gives you like a
like a green tick mark to be like you
did well yeah you did well
it's weird right because um i and i saw
i read about this and it's called a
maximizer and a satisfier right
some people will take the first option
that satisfies them yeah they're okay
with that
there are other people who maximize the
[ __ ] out of everything
yeah and i don't know what happened but
somewhere around the age of
18 to 20 i swapped from being a
maximizer and
literally everything in my life yeah
just being satisfied yeah and like i
remember when i was buying a vacuum for
the first time
holy [ __ ] dude i like spreadsheets on
spreadsheets
i was like yo but the suction power of
this one is 50 watts extra and
[ __ ] this is bristles extra firm ones
now but the reviews of this one
oh my you know what i mean like yeah
yeah yeah we get stressed out about
everything yeah
i haven't that happened with youtube and
stuff but somewhere along the line i
just stopped giving a [ __ ] about
everything
yeah and i'm i'm like now you know even
when i remember i used to book hotels i
used to like i would
i would my god i would search every
hotel like a 10 mile radius
yeah i would have a spreadsheet and i
just got to the point where i realized
i don't think this matters i don't think
i need to do this yeah
and now i just take the first thing that
makes me remotely happy yeah i mean
it's just kind of like decision fatigue
right yeah yeah yeah i do like there's
only so many decisions that you can make
in a day and
there are some points when i'm exactly
the same especially when i'm like
booking a holiday or finding like
even just like choosing what you want to
eat today yeah i
i'd say the only thing i still do it in
my life is for video games like i still
do that for video games but
everything else uh even youtube i just
do what i do and i'm satisfied with that
like i checked the analytics i
you know like roughly but i don't go
deep into them like i just see
you're not like oh my god i'm i'm down
one percent from yesterday yeah
if i gain less subscribers than the
previous day i don't care i'm like i'm
still gaining subscribers
yeah exactly i actually found like a
huge problem for me recently is that
i've
i've found it really hard just to get
into new anime and games
just because like there's so much choice
and i don't know i have this thing where
i'm so
scared of wasting my time see that thing
you need to let go like i had that i had
that yeah i just i just stopped giving a
[ __ ] because like recently okay so i've
the the most recent anime i finished was
one that i had last season it was called
sing yesterday for me and like the first
the first beginning of that was [ __ ]
great i was like i'm good this is gonna
be a show
this is like anime with the season kind
of territory and then i watched it
and the first half was great and then
the second half was just kind of like
nothing's really happening and then it
ended and then it just
it just kind of just ended very fast it
was obviously like a very
rushed ending it was like the most seven
out of ten
overall i remember your tweet where you
were like guys
watching yesterday for me anime of the
season
take it from me the anime zone
like yes you have that story and
i like i just i remember i i finished it
and i knew this was an anime
i'm going to forget in like a month i
mean i'm like that's okay
is it though i think it's okay because
the way i see things right is like no
matter what happens
if i get something i can talk about
that's a win like you you brought it up
it's all about the experience you had
something
you you had something it was the friends
we made along the way
[Laughter]
at the end of the day we're all knocking
my baby if i have something that i can
take away like that that's painfully
mediocre
something i could talk about i can't be
mad but imagine if i didn't have a
podcast where i could just talk
talk about that talk about yourself you
could talk about it to your friends
right you could have said okay
if it had been good would you have been
happy yes no you wouldn't have
you'd have been you'd have been like
satisfied with the choice you made you
wouldn't have been happy i didn't know i
would
like because i know he's just a good
animator
because he wanted it to be an amazing
anime and if it lived up to his
expectations he'd be like good
he wouldn't be like oh my god yes oh i
mean like
i mean i know this guy no no i would be
happy [ __ ] off
[ __ ] you i would be happy i'm happy
watching good anime
just don't show me like okay like okay
the one thing that's even worse than
being a bad anime
is just being a meh anime like yeah like
like
i remember like when i finished domestic
girlfriend like the manga okay
so i finished it like a few weeks ago
[Applause]
it was an awful ending like it was it
was absolutely like one of
one of the worst endings to like a harem
this is the worst trade deal like
they're selling us on this one okay no
no no
like okay just just just just imagine it
right okay this is this is this is what
it was like okay imagine
okay it's it's the world cup final okay
okay
okay no okay in terms of like which girl
is going to win
so it's the world cup final you're in
the 90th minute it's in stoppage time
you're like 10 one up okay and then for
no like the other team is like
completely incapacitated
and then for no reason you decide to
play golden goal and then score an own
goal
that was the ending of domestic
girlfriends well that's that's fun
don't talk about that no no no
but that but that's the thing right is
that because it was so bad
i had a great time like experiencing
just
just the dumpster fire and like the
nuclear fallout that it caused that's
fun right yeah
like i had more fun with them i'm gonna
remember domestic girlfriend for way way
[ __ ] longer right than sing yesterday
for me
because what i'm so scared of is just
i'm gonna watch a show and i'm gonna be
like i'm gonna
and i'm gonna forget the show within a
month but that happens a lot it does
like as somebody who watches so many
[ __ ] documentaries like i watch a lot
of documentaries it's probably
the only thing i really watch on netflix
right kind of come to accept that real
life
doesn't have good enemies unfortunately
like life just
does it just kind of ends it just
doesn't have good endings right
you know and the if you know if you make
documentaries about people who are still
alive
sometimes they keep doing [ __ ] after the
documentary comes out that's like it's
not a complete documentary right but
i don't know i just kind of get ex like
like
satisfied with what i get if it's a good
journey yeah and
if it's a ending that's something i
could talk about that's the way i see it
like and it's a shitty documentary great
i have something to talk about it's a
good documentary
cool i can talk about it like i've just
come to accept that
life just doesn't have good endings it
rarely lives up to the first day but
that on a t-shirt
yeah you know like give one tiger king
first pop is way better than the last
part i mean come on
yeah of course you know what i mean like
it's i don't know i just come to accept
that it was good when it was good and
i'm not gonna get too fussed about it
yeah i mean it's that's the whole thing
right it's it's just this idea of like
you know
nothing in life is pointless like you'll
always find a way to utilize that in
some way and
no matter how [ __ ] mediocre a show is
you're gonna you're gonna use it
somewhere
even if you're not even aware of it
right like yeah
i realize how [ __ ] weird i am right
now because i just don't like story and
video games but i'm happy with mediocre
stories
i mean i don't know it's hard it's this
this is like a debate that i'm trying to
come to terms with myself
yeah is it okay to watch something media
but is it okay to play something for the
story yeah exactly
no everyone's like did you play last of
us no because it's all story
but you get to shoot things in it no
there's no skill involved
you know there's no there's nothing i
can master i love halo and i love
playing the uh
like legendary roots alone where like
it's [ __ ] impossible the [ __ ] driving
up the wall
we sound like every 12 year old i didn't
talk to in school yeah probably
i think we wouldn't get on him if we
went to the same school i would be like
[ __ ] that
jesus christ no but so yeah is there
is there anything else you guys want to
talk about for this podcast bottom line
i don't think conor is ever going to get
into visual novels and that and that's
how it is the more i talk to him the
more i'm like yeah original novel was
you know
it's the natto of anime in my life it's
like
it's a refined taste it's like you
really not even a refined
it's like i feel like you're either
genetically
suppose what's the word like you're
gonna you're more likely to like it
what's the word there's a word for
outfit
supposed or something it's something
along those lines it's not that word
yeah i feel like we're a bit drunk right
i feel like you're either gonna like
visual novels or you're not and you and
you know
if someone explains a visual novel too
you're gonna be like
don't think we're gonna like that yeah
yeah yeah yeah i just i don't know but
like i've never met someone who just
doesn't like story period yeah that's
that's a lot
like like like if you don't like story
in games period then i'm like
i like story not in video games get out
of my video games
bro force amazing game metal slug
amazing game
no stories in those games that's what we
need doing are you telling me you never
looked up the law
of metal slug i i have played
too many hours of metal slug love that
game to death i have no idea if there's
a story
is there a story in metals apparently
there is [ __ ] off no there is
yeah there's apparently the story doom
20 uh the new doom i [ __ ] loved but i
was like wait
wait this cutscene no
no no no no would you not like care
about something like world building for
example
yeah but you can do that through
gameplay yeah but like yeah but it's not
as effective
yeah in my opinion there's like there's
so many okay there's so many games
that right you play the new dooms
you know exactly what the world is about
just from but aren't you like
actually interested in the world no
no and there's your name
i say that right but every time i hear a
piece of like league of legends
i'm like that's cool that's cool and i
actually i'd watch the league of legends
anime
yeah but i don't want to watch league of
legends cut scenes in game imagine you
had to watch cutscenes in league of
legends
connor has like two modes in his brain
yeah and there's like no in between
there's like it's just like shut off
brain um like abs absolutely
anime yeah it's it's it could be [ __ ]
you just like absorb it
or it's like monkey brain mode engage
i am the greatest primate in this group
it's like on or off right like i can sit
there and watch like
any anime or whatever you need me to
watch i could sit there and watch it all
day and be like okay
i know what i'm getting into but when
it's games get that [ __ ] out of here
get that [ __ ] off of me jesus christ
i literally like i love watching tyler
won like live streams
yeah because i feel like he embodies
he's the definition of monkey brain
i love tai lawan as a streamer because
he literally embodies
like not only physically how like i
imagined my gamer side to be
but like watching him play the last of
us was so funny because he was just like
what is this story get this [ __ ] away
from me and i was like i love it i love
it it's so fun
and he's just such a like gigger chad
brain gamer it's so fun to watch him
he's my favorite streamer just because
like i i relate to it oh my god oh god
i guess though you guys can let us know
in the comments below if there is any
visual novel that
you think connor's monkey brain can
handle i've lost
all hope we can't we can't convince them
so maybe you guys can help us yeah okay
you know what before we finish this
people were like yeah i i've beat fire i
was like oh yeah me too
and they were like oh did you play all
the roots i'm like why would i play all
the rooms
i remember talking to you about this i'm
like that that hurts me
i'm like why would i play all the roots
you play blue lines right i play blue
lines which i
you know after i heard about all the
other roots i'm like so i played the
right one
no no no no no no no no there's no right
one yeah that's just one of three yeah
mine sounded like the most so we're
going back into fate now
no no we're not doing this we were close
to ending the episode
all i'm saying is that to me the point
of playing
the same gameplay again for a different
ending is is
it doesn't make any sense to me it's
like
the thought of that is insane i i don't
think
we'll never be able to understand this
no no no no i
i i i i need to students please dissect
i need to do like a full-on study to be
like okay
story you you you like story yeah and
connor's like
yes yes i like story story i like
gameplay you like gameplay
like game yes i like gameplay story and
gameplay
no no a story and
accurate gameplay christ i think that's
why i love arcades because like they
don't try and give you story
it's great they don't try and bog me
down with this [ __ ]
apparently the nostalgia the piano game
has a law
i i can't read japanese so i wouldn't
know anyway you know what game is
amazing with fantastic gameplay and no
story or
chess no story in chess that's why i
like chess so much i think
it started from a young age my diss
please it's actually funny because the
thing i like about chess is the story
and law behind the history of chess
there are two people in the world two
different people in the world right now
but saying that right if you made a
documentary about chess players i'd
[ __ ] love the [ __ ] out of that
because i don't have to it's not like
it's not like because it's not
interjected with because yeah because
it's not
like 10 minutes in move the pawn
it's like okay it's not like because
some of these visual novels have
gameplay and i've seen some of the [ __ ]
and it's like you click one dial
dialogue like thing and it's like why
give me the choice to click yeah exactly
one piece of gameplay is the most
stressful piece of gameplay ever yeah
because it's like
oh my god which one do i choose yeah
exactly right chest the documentary
i would watch chess the game i play
chess the visual novel slash documentary
game
no get that out of here i don't wanna i
don't i don't wanna you are like the
epitome of someone who can't multitask
i actually i actually can't multitask
whatsoever i say shows
yeah maybe i watch anime in the gym
that's about it as far as
wow not as far as gigabrain yeah
what an involved brain you have me
crying on the treadmill
i think i think that's a good place in
this podcast before like we're gonna
need a whole like
study on how connor's brain works but
yeah why is my brain
so smooth you know you know people are
gonna meme the [ __ ] out of this on the
side
please give us your meme your best like
conor is monkey brain check out
our subreddit and our twitter if you
like
also thank you very much to all our
patreons hell yeah
that are on the screen right now those
guys if you like they don't listen to
story
they just want the gameplay if you like
to support us on the show and also fund
the research to try and figure out
conor's monkey brain
the patron is going to help us a lot so
make sure if you enjoyed the show to go
on so patreon
great game no game no story
i kind of want to get tyler one on this
podcast now
tyler1 please come on the podcast and
talk about anime and monkey stuff with
us
oh that would be awesome yeah definitely
uh and also thank you to our sponsor
for this episode as well but yeah i
think that's a good place to end it so
with that said i've been giggling and
joining me today has been monkey brain
oh [ __ ] that's going to be oh we got we
got we got tyler 2 here
and i guess we'll see you all next time
bye bye
janet shut up get this [ __ ] off of me
[Music]
you